[Music]
Petros good morning thanks for joining
us how are you good morning to you Dan
and the dance how are you guys I'm great
out here in LA right how's morale in Los
Angeles if you were recapping the last
couple of days football wise how would
you sum it up morale is kind of like a
family at a table at a restaurant that
just got into a yelling match in front
of a whole bunch of strangers it's a
little bit awkward I don't really I
don't really know how to gauge what
happened in the last couple days because
for 20 years we sat around twenty-plus
and went through every environment
environmental report every stupid thing
that you hear when we talk about
relocation all those words that sports
casters use that they learn in business
class and in graduate school and there
was nothing you know we were just
spinning our wheels and then all of a
sudden within the span of like 13 months
we have two NFL teams and the real crazy
part of it is the most popular team in
LA as the Raiders that's coming here so
it is a little awkward
but at the same time for us media types
it's very interesting because we have
breaking news to cover and to freak out
about and talk about logos and all that
but is San Diego or the Chargers sort of
forcing their way in like we're here so
deal with us is does LA care that the
Chargers are in town III don't think
outwardly right now they do now there
are some interesting nuances to this and
you understand the NFL very well you
know San Diego is its own market it's
its own place it has its own unique
identity it doesn't want to be
associated with LA it's only real
association with Los Angeles is that
it's also in Southern California so the
Chargers have nothing to do with Los
Angeles and nobody really feels
connected to them but the intriguing
part of play at the former Home Depot
Center now the StubHub center that only
has 30,000 C
is gonna feel a little bit like old keys
or Stadium or something like that and
those seats will go at a premium and
they have a good quarterback and they
have a new coach so maybe they can sell
that and maybe the thing that trumps the
fact that the Rams lost a lot of
interest in town shortly after the
preseason and the fact that nobody cares
about the Chargers maybe the stadium Dan
maybe that Taj Mahal Dallas type of
place or the place like in Arlington
maybe that erases all of this and it
becomes a big attraction in town but
right now there's just a bunch of
question marks speaking of which would
you think of the the new logo for the
Chargers you know people really people
really attacked it so did I yeah I don't
know if they gave it that much thought
petrol so it feels like they went oh we
got to have a logo here how about we
just do a ban it at the end of the
Dodgers logo yeah that'll be like a
lightning bolt yeah that'll do it here
we go
yeah what I thought it looked like is
what somebody tweeted me I thought was
the most appropriate it looked like my
whole high school career you know
copying somebody's homework but try not
to make it look exactly like their
homework just you know throwing a little
nuance on it here they're getting a
couple wrong just to throw the teacher
off but then all of a sudden the Spanos
family back pedaled on the radio
yesterday saying no no no that's not our
permanent label that was just like a
holding label and I don't know what I
made a lot of people are smarter than me
but I don't know what a holding label is
to me you put out your logo that's your
logo but I think they got so much
backlash that they that their backlash
there that they're backpedaling but at
the same time the Clippers could have
done the same on Chuck the Condor but
they stuck with their gun I also wanted
to ask you about this because you played
college football at USC when you have a
head coach who is younger than you how
do you think this plays how long does
this player is is an issue with the Rams
that Shaun McVeigh is thirty years of
age you know I don't know him like like
I know some coaches here and there but
when a guy's thirty years old it makes
you think well who hired him and the guy
that hired him is a
guy that's coming into a lot of question
gavin demo the guy that hired jeff
fisher the guy that fired jeff fisher
the guy that allowed jeff fisher to hire
a novice offensive coordinator to help
out a rookie quarterback learn to take
snaps under center so there's a lot of
missteps here and it looks like a young
guy hiring somebody that he could
control as opposed to hiring a coach
that's going to come in and and take the
lion's share of the responsibility of
building the team and in doing that sort
of stuff
to be honest it kind of reminds me as
you mentioned college football of the
situation when Lane Kiffin was hired by
Mike Garrett at USC after the P Carroll
departure to Seattle which was hey we're
hiring this young guy who's
inexperienced and this and that but he's
gonna bring his dad and he's gonna bring
a tow Geron and that's kind of what's
happening here with McVeigh they're
saying well we're bringing this young
guy and but he's bringing the gray head
Wade Phillips and he's gonna provide the
stability well they already had a
defensive super bowl-winning coach in
Gregg Williams yeah so you know there's
still a just a lot of a lot to be
desired about the management of the Rams
since they came to Los Angeles how would
you grade Jared Goff first year I'd give
him a B I guess you know it's not his
fault to be to be completely Frank he
had not a not a high grade offensive
coordinator or at least that was
considered to be that in borås wanky
what was not coming out of a lot of NFL
experience as a coach and then all of a
sudden you know here's a guy from one of
those Sonny dykes types of offenses
where you're taking shotgun snaps and
you know doing a lot of play action with
zone read stuff and all of a sudden you
want him to look down the field and read
progression and play in a pro style
offense to me I didn't think he wasn't a
prospect I mean the guy has a talented
arm we saw him a bunch on the west coast
but why give up all those picks and take
them at number one you put yourself
behind the eight-ball
because he looks like a baby giraffe
under center I mean he doesn't have the
muscles in his ass you know he doesn't
have the muscles in his legs to drop
back and look like a man yet and when
that's the number one pick in the draft
that that's a bad look so they needed to
hire a savvy barnacle filled offensive
coordinator last year to work with him
and and they didn't and we'll see what
they do with this young guy but he's got
a 30 year old that's in charge that
looks like Shaun from The Bachelor well
we thought that he might be a Gosling
type I mean you got you can who's
better-looking the coach or the
quarterback you know I'm gonna say the
coach has a little bit of a Jayhawk in
them you know it looks like somebody hit
him right the red guy with a big huge
elastic you know so he's got that bruise
dasu stops from Moran you know Golf is
from Marin Catholic he's pretty you know
he's from the Bay Area and not just the
Bay Area you know he's from where where
where Sean Penn used to live with Robin
right where they used to put it down
so he's special good to talk to you
Petros tell money we settle Oh always
nice to be on thanks for having me
whenever I come on the show I get a
bunch of facts to say you better not
screw up are you and are you and Seton
is the show and Seton are you guys on
good terms
Seton in money here I'd like to feel
everything's queen and 2017 you know
Seton is that where you stand with money
bet you know what that's such old news I
don't even remember what you're talking
about it's water under the bridge we're
all good
we've all hugged it out many times I I
still go back to that Super Bowl party
where you had a Budweiser in your hand
and next thing I know it was almost go
time between Seaton and money how would
that have played out Seaton against
money gosh you know I never seen that in
a fight but he had a little more weight
to him back then you know now he's run a
bunch of marathon real skinny yeah
it would have been a radio war I mean
there's
it would not fit man Cal versus Howard
Stern and such a radio flash yes eating
two dudes and skinny jeans yelling at
each other yeah holding Budweiser's not
really over the Arcade Fire yeah
Petros thanks for joining us have a good
weekend thank you all right at Petros
Papadakis is co-host of petrol Simoni on
am 570 la sports the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]